pas alors à ce qu'est ce que tu proposes
alors moi j'ai trouvé je vais trouver le
mec qui rit qui réagit permal à une
vanne mais en fait ils se trompent de
cible
totalement d'accord ils se trompent
d'ennemi co voilà totalement
voilà c c'est cocasse et c'est à la fois
aussi très touchant aux condamnés à
trois à baba même rafa il est d'accord
avec moi ça ne m'a pas ma gloire
imaginez le mariage le moment le plus
solennel de ta vie tu payes un dj très
cher il te casse sa vie non mes images
et
[Musique]
j'ai trompé il est rempli évidemment son
ordinateur il a tout pété avec des
hurlements fans et fait chaud que ça va
c'est pas moi ça me choque ça me chaînon
mais pas drôle allez on généralement
quand on s'endort on est aspiré par des
rêves on est aspiré à vendre un truc
toit et les regardent ou pas un combat
voilà ça là où est là mais là là là
c'est une autre aspiration là quand on
dort
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fadi qu'elle est bel et bien à la mairie
de très jolis l'aspirante bros c'est bon
c'est ainsi morgan
alors parfois dans la vie on est fier de
nous quand on fait des choses marrantes
on a envie de le filmer que tout le
monde le sache et puis c'est pas
toujours une bonne idée on est chaud le
bêtisier c'est quoi
rozier elle a embrassé le bêtise état
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça va bien je les ôter ses habits mais
c'est rien elle c'est est ce qu'on
appelle une bogdanov
[Rires]
elle va mieux elle va bien tout va bien
pour elle elle est entre de bonnes mains
et c'est bon alors vous inquiétez pas
tout va bien pas l'interet de poils
alors pour moi est ce que ça bah non je
n'en finis pas encore mais c'est la
meilleur de moi c'est la meilleure du
jour est d'accord allez siphonner la
campagne alors hier fabien d'abord très
bien j'ai un truc qui peut qui peut
rivaliser
elle n'a pas pipé actifs tu as des trois
semaines ouais mais avec un tapis
toujours pas pu y perd actifs qui veut
la foire
je crois qu'il enfonce oui des fonds se
soldent hockey dans le salon l'autre ils
n'arrivent pas à moi pour ma gloire
non non non et à la fois qu'est-ce qui
était qu'à son avis il enfants sont ils
des fonds ce qui est non je crois qui tu
as en fait c'est l'agent stone dans
l'état et puis en même temps il veut
boire et vous allez voir c'est il fait
deux choses en même temps ça alors
qu'evian si quelqu'un a compris ce n'est
pas du tout ce qu'on va voir mais
apparemment c'est drôle ouais ouais
bonsoir
la première fois glos sabah pas gologo
l'entrevue on la franchit d'attention
ludivine alors vous savez comment ça se
passe à la salle de sport au bout de moi
je sais si vous savez ça c'est parce que
vous les lancements des eaux cette c'est
à la salle de sport les mecs aiment se
la raconter tout ça na na na hey mec
oui comme mon mec exacte et ce afin que
son mec et le gamin ça m'a mis au
courant et à la salle de sport ilves a
raconté le mien il vous sera content en
tout cas c'est que j'ai beau gosse autre
nom mais qui est très bonne à mais
arrêtez un peu ça va même bien méritée
mais bon je vois bien qu'elle a roulé
son numéro en question
ok donc à la salle de sport ou même se
la raconter celui que je vous présente
et il a voulu tout donner du coup il a
un petit peu trop donné regarde la salsa
certains lancements
c'est pas du tout ce qu'on voit au tibia
[Musique]
saigon 20 ans
[Applaudissements]
vu
et kaïs hamas mais oui mais pour
l'instant pour l'instant c'est fabien
que c'est bien mais ça joue autres
fabien et tiffany qui est championne
internationale
lolo c'est à toi alors je vais lancer
cette séquence par une comptine pour
enfant asie où la chair cher ou bien
vite me boucher
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il a bercé raphaël qui décident rappel
pour toi quelle était la vidéo la plus
drôle c tiffany ce sens
[Applaudissements]
chantal toi
bravo
[Applaudissements]